hello and welcome to this video this is
a fourth video of the reddit opening of
the week week three of 2016 battling
rare moose with white quality better
whites rare moves with black that would
be the right way to put it
so we checked b3 b4 and 93 up to now and
yeah going with my from right to left
from blacks point of view I'm method
it's time for the birds opening but I
felt that f4 was a little bit more
tricky than I thought
not that this is I mean my problem there
was that what I wanted to do is mostly
treat it as a Dutch defense reversed and
this is kind of a little bit much
especially if you recommend it to people
who usually play one year for that
they're all of a sudden play the Dutch
with colors reversed anyway I take a
little bit longer to have something
independent against f4 and do that at
the yeah this is the last video that's
going to come and therefore I will go to
the G pawn moves now and that will do
one g3 and one G form in one video which
is a bit strange mainly because g3 is
probably the best move for all the rare
ones and G for the worst so it's kind of
a weird coupling but I felt that if I do
a separate video on g4 on a separate one
on g3 will be pretty short video so
let's get going let's start with g4 the
group opening yeah named after Henry
grope who's yeah notorious famous for
inventing that opening I also wanted to
mention a funny quote that I once read
in a chess magazine broke was if I
remember correctly married nine times
and at one point he was asked by someone
mister group are you married and he
replied almost always it's a very funny
reply in my mind anyway so group where
he was a obviously quite um you know
adventurous person what you call it yeah
nine wives okay anyway he played g4
he's the inventor all that move the
namesake yeah as I said in early videos
it's not particularly great but we also
cannot expect to refute it like from the
get-go you can now play of course
whatever you like in a way but my
recommendation is to go for with d5 that
has a clear logic at the Texas pawn
right now it has a choice you can cover
it or play Bishop g2 Bishop g2 yeah it's
in a way gambit in that Jeep on but
still the most popular move after age 3
if we look at this
I recommend to play e5 just occupying
the center yeah that's very logical well
why does horsing around there on the
flank we occupy the center
what now goes Bishop g2 and my
recommendation is to go c6 you can also
play other setups 96 also it's quite
interesting but I think that this kind
of setup is something to remember
against the Grove and you can play that
pretty much regardless of what is doing
here White has to do something about the
center and they usually play d4 if white
does something else this is usually d3
and my recommendation is just to develop
simply like with this possibly night
here and yeah being flexible about the F
pawn sometimes you can use the F pawn or
the aged pawn to attack White's yeah
White's flanked on there on G form um
against deform I think blacks best is to
advance and take that space here white
normally tries to attack this this pawn
chain makes a lot of sense and play C
form
yeah and I believe here black has a good
position we can again just develop
freely with Bishop d6 Knight c3 Knight
to e7 this is a good setup not 9 f6
now after which g5 is disturbing the
night
night is good only seven we support d5
and we ask right how is going to develop
him an interesting moment arises after
Queen to b3 that that move attack is a
d5 pawn yeah him black and just castle
and be okay but I was quite surprised to
see that the number one recommendation
or stock fishes b5 with an advantage to
black it was kind of funny yeah what is
the what is the point yeah white takes
the pawn and now after Queen takes we go
Bishop d7 Queen b3 Knight p c6 and this
is a fantastic compensation for the pawn
yeah I mean black is developed fully
almost yeah we get another another tempo
and this is just just fantastic
fantastic for black somewhat better is
to take with the night but again not be
c6 gives black fantastic compensation we
have given a pawn on the B file there
but our development is great we get
loopy aid we cancel we've got f5 I mean
this is a fantastic position like just
has a great initiative for the pawn okay
that's probably not the most relevant
line but I found b5 was a very very nice
suggestion by the engine in general this
kind of central formation makes lots of
sense it blunts this Bishop and we have
a central central advantage yeah this is
h3 basically sometimes they play Bishop
g2 just neglecting this pawn yeah in
fact I still recommend to play c6 to
let's say keep it simple after c6 why it
has nothing better than h3 relay and
then if I've transposes to the line that
we have looked at so a very simple
solution here and one thing however is
what you can try which is very
interesting if you want some some funny
place of sharp play you can take on g4
um white go c4 and white some yeah
White's wise trick in a way here is
something like that
C 6 T X T X naught C 3 is 6
Queen a 4 and map yeah this is something
to avoid
but what black can do is he can actually
take this pawn this is very interesting
because white will take you
that's the only move making some kind of
sense I mean why these two points down
yes two takes take something now take
here and now 97 giving away the exchange
the position here is in fact excellent
yeah after a three there's five the only
reason why I'm not recommending this is
my my main my main line is that yeah it
is kind of its kind of crazy and try to
offer people who play the group they
want this kind of weird irrational
positions however objectively speaking
black is quite fine Ian yeah I said
excellent a minute ago is probably a bit
much but I think like gets great
compensation here for the small maturity
investment White's King is in bad shape
and black has all the fun so this is
especially interesting in a short time
control gamer and well you never get you
for probably oh very rarely so it's not
a huge point but still it's interesting
to know this little idea if someone
Springs this upon you in a blitz game
you have completely got taken over the
initiative here after after six moves um
yeah this is basically the growth yeah
not much more to know there are a couple
of other things that that black can try
even even this is probably pretty good
but it's no particular reason to study
that just take the center place is six
to blunt the bishop and black is more
than okay so the Jeep on 2-1-1 g3 and g3
this is more this is a wiser move of
course then g4 it doesn't weaken so much
and maybe objectively speaking the most
promising of all of the
non-common who it's probably the fifth
best move of his most popular move after
d4e for c4 and NIDA three in fact
g3 has relatively little independent
value as we have tons of trans positions
for example whenever white plays a move
Knight f3 in one of the next moves we
very likely transpose to some Kings
Indian attack or some kind of reti
opening if you play c4 in one of the
next two moves three moves we probably
go to some kind of English opening and
sometimes that's rarely happens but
sometimes white play something like d3
and d4 and keeps the the knight back on
on g1 then sometimes even a closed
Sicilian can occur and the independent
value of the set is relatively little
and what you mostly have to keep in mind
is black against g3 that you're not
getting both ordered into something that
you don't know at all or don't have in
your repertoire for example if you play
e5 you must be ready for white playing
c4 which is maybe objectively speaking
in the best move going to an English
opening all of a sudden c-45 g3 so if
you don't have the English with one e5
in your repertoire d5 is tricky business
if you have that in your repertoire if
five makes a lot of sense now II five
and if they don't play C form your next
move is d5 if you play the move c5 which
you can do then after c4 we got a
symmetrical English it's also something
to be ready for them you of course can
also play some kind of Kings Indian
setup Knight f6 g6 and so on that's also
possible what relatively inoffensive
move gives black a huge choice it is
very important to understand that you're
all free virgins pose it to something
and keeping that in mind makes quite
some sense so I don't have a very
clear-cut recommendation
it is a completely respectable move it's
not like okay like after before RG 4 you
have some clear way of getting very
comfortable quality or an advantage
that's not the case here however what
can happen is that you play d5 or a5
let's say this and now if they don't
play Nydia 3 and go here that you get
this position this is something that
might frequently occur and if you play
d5 or if I if it makes sense to play the
the partner move next you know move want
to build up that Center this is
something that I want to look at briefly
in this video because it's the most
let's say independent kind of system
that white can go for after one g3 in
this position um white mostly goes for
two moves D 3 and C 4 if Y play C form
you have a choice between a couple of a
couple of decent moves my main
recommendation is to play D form and
gain the space in the center however if
you don't like there was closed
positions you can also play Knight f6
which supposes to an English opening
again yeah after C takes Knight X and so
on we get a mainland English was from C
45 or you can if you want to avoid this
kind of theory of the mainland English
but still want more of an open position
you can capture on C form this is also
quite simple and not bad at all yeah the
positions like after here in c6 Queen
takes and 90 of 6 and these positions we
also resemble some kind of reversed
Sicilian yeah something that could
happen from an opening lucky for see 593
g6g for Bishop g7 D takes e5 Queen a5
check now black just develops normally
Bishop to e6 maybe Bishop here castles
if you want some kind of open semi open
position this is a good decent choice a
bit more ambitious is defo well there
are also some lines that are not so
sharp after that but yeah gaining the
center again in spades in the center and
not simplifying it said it's the move t4
yeah d3 is normal knight c6 Knight f3
Knight f6 Castle this kind of setup is
quite quite normal I just wanted to
mention one particular point because it
still happens in many games that black
is making a typical mistake here the
move Bishop to e7 this is known for a
very long time actually but so people
fail to recognize the movement before
him this is actually quite awkward for
black yeah Bishop takes 95 is quite an
awkward with this idea yeah or just
Knight takes Knight takes and white
again is better having traded a B pawn
against an e pawn this can be avoided by
means of playing Bishop to d6 or a5
which is my recommendation here simply
playing against any V form yeah I think
after this black has decent chances for
equality or probably will get equality
the position or ever can be quite
interesting night a3 for example is an
interesting move after which black will
continue normally why place B 392 a3 and
we have a typical reversed can of benoni
position sometimes why players try to
open up the center and use their
potential development advantage here my
advice is to take on a3 not to let why
take on d4 a position like like this for
example can be tricky for black when the
D pawn could be a weakness and white has
easy plans so absurd now I know I
completely scratched
thing I was a bad idea but okay let's
let's get there again by a transposition
a53 cheeks cheeks yeah this is much
better
yeah taking only three and developing
yeah hear it most of the time it gets to
a position like that king snakes stick
sticks and now some c6 and Bishop e6
after which black has equalized even
though the position is not super
exciting has to be has to be said yeah
this is what I think is good against
against c4 if we go back here let's by
the way also the option of playing c6
however I am not completely sure how to
assess this kind of position if black
takes it I think what maybe has some
good prospects after neither 3 and E 4
might be might be good but it's very
demanding from the black player to play
especially if white knows what he's
doing what war with 93 possibly oops in
Knight to f4 we get some pressure on the
d5 pawn and this can be quite tricky to
play so I wasn't sure that this is a
good recommendation just d4 or taking on
I'd f6 for more open position is good
the other move is d3 that gets
frequently played and here I recommend
to play knight c6 no Knight f3 is quite
logical yeah and now black has a pretty
wide choice the most popular move here
is to play Knight to f6 and then Bishop
e7 which can easily transpose to what we
have looked just a couple of moments ago
even though here before is again again
possible okay you can castle
my recommendation is different I have
excellent experience with the setup of
g6 um that is I think quite interesting
the idea is that black is setting up
something like this and castles h6
and just develop Bishop e6 Queen d7 just
normal development this is a very
comparable system against the Kurds
defense with g3 and this is the same
thing with the tempo down which is
largely irrelevant so this is also a
pretty good setup
what is somewhat risky and I wouldn't
recommend is black playing something
very ambitious here some have five for
example yeah this is I mean it's not
like totally bad but it stretches things
a little bit yeah black playing as a
deceiver wide and well white has dynamic
counter play quite often with c4 and so
on so I wouldn't wouldn't shoot for that
yeah g3 as I said it's heavily
transpositional if you don't mind the
English with with c4 c5 is a good move
here or let's say yeah you don't mind
this and if five is very good then
easiest for many people who will be to
play d5 as after Knight f3 they might
have this in your repertoire or play
something with c6 again Nydia three
based systems anyway and very often what
will play Knight a three-year one thing
you have to be aware of though is that
why it is still able to play the move f4
in some situations so then Sam there
might be some systems where Y tries to
be clever and let's say it starts with
things like that and like it was here
let's say and white plays f4 and then
you're committed to a set up against the
birds opening that you maybe did not
want to play in the first place
in general I see no reason for a black
to not occupy the center here so my
general advice even though black is very
flexible against b3 is to put one of the
pawns in the center and if what allows
it to get to take t-55 here and just
take that center it's
prevents many uncomfortable kind of
trans positions and limits White's
option also because if you take the
center
you're always reducing the opponent's
possibilities one little remark though
if white tries to go to a birds opening
now with f1 then recommendation in from
a bird video will be mentioned now h5 is
very interesting now this very brutal
kind of way to proceed is in fact pretty
good for black so this is something that
I will talk about in my opening on the
birds the bird opening yeah this was the
video about g3 and g4 g4 not much to
worry about it's a bit wacky and yeah
you can fight fire with fire with that
exchange sacrifice of white allows it
otherwise take the scent and enjoy life
against them g3 a recommendation is to
put both those pawns in the center even
though it is there's nothing to be said
against g6 or c5 or whatever you want
you just have to make sure that you're
not tricked into some kind of thing that
you don't know playing let's say the
English opening all of a sudden and
having no idea about it because you
never play 1.e4 and normally answer 1c
46 then yeah then it's pretty pretty bad
yeah there's also by the way nothing
wrong with playing a set up based on d5e
6 Knight f6 Bishop e7 this kind of
classical Queens gambit type of setup
yeah white will very likely transpose
into some kind of Catalan or already
opening even though if you voluntarily
let's say limit yourself in some way
like this maybe like if you if you for
example play here is 6 which is I don't
know why you would do that but let's say
you do umm yeah these kind of ideas get
more interesting now maybe trying to
shoot for some some center here that
that polar bear setup and that could
could happen so no reason to be that
modest just grab the center and be happy
with it okay I hope you enjoyed this
overview over the about the Jeep or
moose G for ng3 and the final video in
that series will be about the bird
opening probably to be released on
Saturday or Sunday
I don't sure what I'm going to be able
to do probably only on Sunday okay well
thanks for watching